China imported over 5 billion dollars of
U.S corn last year even though it's the
world's second largest producer of the
crop the world's top producer is the US
and most of the Corn these countries are
producing isn't even eaten by people
about 75 percent of China's corn and 40
of the US's is used for animal feed
livestock get fatter when they're fed
corn and China's growing middle class is
eating more and more meat China now
needs about 250 million metric tons of
corn per year so much corn that it has
to import millions of tons from other
countries and now China has begun
working to cut its Reliance on foreign
corn particularly from the U.S any
country that's trying to maintain
livestock you know be it cows pigs what
have you they need to have corn but
China's Farms like far behind the U.S
which is a major concern for its food
security here's why growing its own
grains has been such a struggle for
China and how it's been trying to wean
itself off U.S corn which could leave a
significant Gap in America's sport
Market
U.S farmers are much more successful at
growing corn in their counterparts in
China the U.S department of Agriculture
estimates that China's cornfields
yielded less than three tons per acre
last year versus nearly five in the U.S
it's widely believed from you know the
folks that I saw to that the U.S has you
know the superior soil the superior
farming techniques the U.S has
significantly more arable land than
China and the arable land that China
does have is decreasing due to
urbanization
China soil is also heavily polluted a
2014 report found nearly one-fifth of
the country's arable land was
contaminated with heavy metals China is
currently conducting a national soil
survey to see the extent of the issue a
second key Advantage for U.S Farmers is
their growing practices to try and grow
more Chinese farmers use massive amounts
of fertilizer more than four times the
global average many Chinese farmers are
using fertilizer inefficiently and
polluting the larger ecosystem in the
process a third issue for Chinese
Farmers their seeds are about 20 years
behind U.S technology many in China are
suspicious of genetically modified crops
but the government has worked to
overcome that skepticism even in its
recent push to embrace genetically
modified corn China only allowed a tiny
fraction of its cornfields to be planted
with genetically modified seeds
according to reports so China has turned
to the U.S for corn while its banned
domestic Farmers from growing
genetically modified corn due to public
opposition China has still imported
genetically modified corn to feed
animals but as tensions have escalated
between the two countries China has put
more effort into finding alternative
trade Partners to get the resource
adding competition to the market they're
in the process of
setting up kind of their own Trade
Network that can support their you know
population in their economy and do so in
a way where they're free of uh you know
free of U.S influence free of Western
influence in general namely this means
turning to Brazil which is right behind
the U.S and China when it comes to corn
production for China they're in the
process of seeking out other countries
that can handle uh their demand and
which is why Brazil is a key partner
that they're developing a stronger
partnership with it's because Brazil is
able to grow as a corn producing country
and they you know see that growth as
supportive for their demand going
forward for a long time Brazil was known
for having a volatile corn Supply but
the country is now producing far more
corn than ever before increasing how
many acres are planted and growing a
second crop of corn after Farmers
Harvest soybeans it hasn't had to do
everything on its own foreign businesses
have been investing in Brazil's
agriculture for decades Chinese
companies have spent billions to get
involved in the growing Latin American
market and everything from seeds to
processing and transportation things
have shifted even further since the war
in Ukraine for years China was getting
lots of its corn there Ukraine is one of
the world's largest corn producers but
its corn production has fallen
significantly in the past few years the
war has made it harder for Farmers to
get financing for corn season fertilizer
and some Farmland has been unusable due
to occupation or mines so China has
doubled down on its relationship with
Brazil last year China signed an
agreement to allow significantly more
corn imports from the country the result
Brazil May surpass the U.S in corn
exports this year Brazil is receiving
increased market share of exports that
used to be in the US's domain there's
competitions for prices who has the most
competitive prices and Brazil often wins
that because Brazil still has lots of
room to expand its corn growing acreage
it could soon surpass the US in corn
production there's a lot of room to grow
and that's what they're doing they're
aggressively growing this could pose
significant competition for the U.S
especially in light of other
circumstances facing the country's corn
Market the U.S is currently facing a
trade dispute with its second biggest
corn customer Mexico which plans to ban
genetically modified corn by the end of
2023 the country says this is to
preserve heirloom varieties of corn that
grow domestically but it's a big deal
since more than 90 percent of U.S grown
corn is genetically modified export
markets are always a top concern if
China is no longer purchasing or you
know exports in general or to drop off
in the price that farmers are going to
receive at the grain elevators for their
crop have the potential to sink for
Farmers that are you know already
operating on really thin margins that's
very difficult and you know a lot of
times when this kind of thing happens
you know there's some Farmers that
simply cannot overcome that U.S Farmers
could potentially sell more corn to
ethanol plants that could use it to make
fuel but losing the export Market could
significantly lower prices they wouldn't
be able to cover the amount of volume
that China and exports in general take
up from U.S producers they wouldn't be
able to cover that just through ethanol
alone ultimately China aims to grow all
the basic grains it needs whether that's
corn wheat rice or soybeans but corn is
just one crop where China's Crop
Production falls short the country also
relies on foreign soybeans it imported
over 16 billion dollars worth from the
U.S last year soybeans and corn often
grow on the same land but corn is more
productive China's average soybean yield
per acre is less than one-third that of
corn and is about 40 percent less than
the United States average soybean yield
for the same plot
some Chinese researchers have been
urging Farmers to adopt new planting
methods that could allow them to grow
both soy and corn but they worry Farmers
prefer to just stick with what they're
already doing experts believe China
could grow self-sufficient in corn
production by the end of the decade the
recombination of better planting
practices using cornbread to maximize
growth and improving the soil quality
but that would require embracing new
technology and farmer education they
would have to grow significantly more in
order to be self-sufficient the way that
the U.S is and they would have a long
way to go to do that for the foreseeable
future China will probably need to keep
importing large amounts of corn if it
wants to keep using it in animal feed
but soon that may no longer mean buying
from the U.S China is in the position uh
where they don't have enough to feed
their people which is why they import
from you know outside and they've been
reliant on us as the primary corn
producer in the world even if they
really don't want to do business with us
that's why they're building trade
agreements that you know you can
essentially go around the US the US
doesn't really have an alternative to
China in terms of the buying power that
they have Farmers have seen what can
happen when China stops buying U.S
agricultural Goods when China sharply
reduced orders for products like corn
and soybeans in 2018 Farms hit record
levels of debt despite the US government
responding with billions in Aid if China
stops buying U.S corn again and moves
its business to countries like Brazil
Farmers would need to find a replacement
but having to replace a 5 billion dollar
export Market could be a major problem
for farmers who are already getting by
on thin margins
foreign
[Music]